what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today hey greg you're wearing
that chong chi shirt you were in the
video you went to premiere yeah
water
that's all i'll say i'll say is water
guys look um we got star wars vision
trailer the official one today i'm i'm
already really looking forward to this i
i want to see more properties do things
like this taking popular stuff and
making it into anime i really love that
approach that i approach but we have a
dub and we have the original and i've
been uh deliberating back and forth on
which version do we want to watch this
and i'm often a purist when it comes to
anime so i prefer
sub but i don't know what the audience
wants so we're going to watch both we're
going to watch both we'll start with the
original
and then we'll watch the dub and then
we'll give thoughts and then maybe from
there we'll decide which one's our
preference i already feel like i'm
already biased towards one let's
american celebrities
[Music]
look how cool this looks
[Applause]
i am loving this already
[Music]
awesome
i love the music
feels like they had a matrix
yeah
[Music]
are they pottery
[Music]
look at that boba
oh
[Applause]
are they having a lightsaber battle
in space it looks like it
with a flexible lightsaber blade on that
sith one
i gotta admit man harry may the force be
with you in japanese sounded awesome
yeah
i really love that i mean
i i really visceral spot i've already
sold them the japanese version but let's
see if this creates some conflict let's
watch the english one now
long ago
a great warrior came to this village
and entrusted our ancestors with this
its power and responsibility
now lie with you
[Music]
that dude looks like michael shannon
[Applause]
god that shot
at least they're doing japanese accents
except for their
it's the first time i've confronted such
darkness
[Music]
something ancient and sinister
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
still had her say in japanese yeah
it's the one line
oh
[Applause]
god
[Applause]
[Music]
i accept this responsibility
i mean
it's it just feels so appropriate and
with
jedi being inspired by samurai to have
the japanese anime angle on it really
feeling like you have sci-fi
space
samurais
at play here like the action scenes just
look so sweeping i heard that they're
not aiming to have to tie this into
the the actual like original saga itself
yeah at least that's what i've heard so
i don't know
really i recognize boba fett that's
about it i really know the other
characters yeah that's not kylo ren
right i don't i don't think so i mean i
feel like they would have had adam
driver or somebody come back because i
think i think i read tomorrow morrison
is at least supposed to be uh his voice
well that means american cast yeah
okay here's my conflict right when the
show comes out near it keep keep a
lookout for our community page and we'll
put it on twitter too we'll we'll have
people vote of you know what which one
to cover whether it be the english or
the uh japanese version
i personally wait even watching the
trailer i'm like i way prefer the
japanese version it just fits a lot
better and also like with the english
dub at least it it fits it sounds like
like when you get an anime show you
bring it to the states and they get
really great voice over actors it has
that new wants and that layer to it so
it doesn't look bad or unappealing it's
just what is definitely more of a
preference even watching it back
i i actually thought it would be a
little worse about it but it wasn't bad
to me so i could watch either one but i
would leave it up to the people like
which one would you prefer us to do
reactions to because obviously we'd have
to
you know like with disney plus we we
have to usually make that a little oval
thing which puts us in a corner because
we don't want to cut off the subtitles
yeah we get paid in the ass to watch our
reactions to something like that we'd
want people to be able to enjoy our
reactions it wouldn't be too much to be
looking at us and having to read along
whenever there's footage on screen you
know so i'm like ultimately it sounds
easier for a viewing experience for
audiences who watch us to watch us cover
the the english one
um
but uh yeah on a personal level i would
prefer the japanese version but yeah
this looks great this looks awesome
don't really know all details what's
going on and i love that
and uh looks sweeping and uh feel and i
love the variety because like i said
animatrix because animatrix had
different anime styles
to each one of the installments similar
to this so looks cool johnny yeah
absolutely i mean i love the idea of
doing that they got like you know nine
of the biggest you know producers of
anime now to you know contribute to
these stories and to really i from what
i the sense i get run off with them and
really have creative freedom with them
so i love the vibe that that gives off
here and the way that yeah you have all
these different approaches to the style
and the format and that gives it almost
a timeless quality because some of this
looks like more retro anime some of this
looks like very modern anime and i just
loved yeah the amount of like
lore and co like star wars is full of
lauren culture and star wars has also
been inspired by and inspired various
anime and so yeah it feels really
appropriate to then do an interlude you
know like this and have these stories
that who knows could connect because
from what i understand they're at least
spread out throughout the timeline of
the saga that we know from at least the
movies and such um and and from what i
also heard there's like a book that ties
into one of these so like it seems
really creative and i love when they
decide to you know go out and branch out
this way i love everything you had to
say john those are the best words thank
you
guys what do you think about star wars
visions are you excited for it are you
still anti-star wars
thoughts down below subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
and they are dropping all this at once
versus a weekly release which i find
very interesting wonder what the choice
on that part was but either way let's do
a pic
john i think you could successfully
shout out scuba steve because you know
scuba steve he
is someone with a variety
uh he does graffiti art he could
probably draw
anime
he could really put his own style
into something like this in fact i could
see him being hired
to being uh one of the artists who work
on any star wars animated property
and i could
definitely see him using his own
flourishes to create his own story i
also think you could probably mention
how he's like so creative he's very
inventive
and using what he's naturally inclined
to do you could probably also mention
how
he
has a great detail to physique and
anatomy
so he could bring a lot of those touches
in so i really believe that if you shout
him out he'd be perfect for this okay
you're taking too long this is done
scuba steve uh you can do a star wars
[Music]
you